We Begin this hour with the new Museum
reclaiming a site that holds a solemn
place in American history the
international African-American museum
opened its doors on the Charleston South
Carolina waterfront earlier this summer
the 120 million dollar project is no
ordinary tourist attraction Mark
Strassman shows us why its location and
Mission are so important
this is an American story you feel it
throughout Charleston's new
international African-American Museum
the power of resilience I think
sometimes we need to be shocked Malika
Pryor guided us through nine galleries
that track America's original sin the
history of the Middle Passage more than
12 million enslaved people shipped from
Africa as human cargo their anguish and
despair what did they lose what did they
have to sacrifice what did they have to
hide but exhibits also pay homage to
something else faith that freedom would
one day be theirs I expect different
people to feel different things Tanya
Matthews the CEO of this Museum built on
scarred and sacred ground gadsden's
Wharf the arrival point for nearly half
of all enslaved Africans shipped to the
U.S we were able to find this outline of
what had been a building and we believe
that it was one of the many store houses
we do know that captured Africans once
they were brought into the wharf were
often or in many cases held in these
storehouses awaiting their price to
increase this is a site of trauma but
look who's standing here now that's what
makes it a sight of joy and Triumph
you're going to walk in this space and
you are going to engage and what it
means to you is going to be
transformational by Design you feel all
that it's not a museum about slavery but
a monument to Freedom so this entire
thing tells me a whole lot about how
complicated my past has been
representative James kleiber South
Carolina's veteran Congressman
championed this project for more than 20
years it has the chance of being the
most consequential thing that I've ever
done you see this
with pride as a legacy project no
question about that an American Legacy
the intersection of trauma and Triumph
for CBS mornings Mark Strassman in
Charleston South Carolina
I want to go I want to go just to meet
Tanya Matthews right it's such a Regal
presence I like it I want to go to that
place yeah and I like what Mark said it
in a legacy project yeah the
intersection of trauma and Triumph yeah
exactly that's my point as well they
balance it too very well